zdf heute live es gibt neuigkeiten zur
amokfahrt in berlin von gestern und
mittlerweile kann man von einer
amokfahrt sprechen denn die
staatsanwaltschaft hat sich dazu
geäußert bevor wir hören was neuigkeiten
von juristischer sicht gibt schauen wir
zuerst mal dort an den tatort carsten
behrendt wie gestern schon den ganzen
tag ist auch heute für uns dort vor ort
und vielleicht fangen wir mit etwas an
was bei all dem trubel immer zu kurz
kommt mit der anteilnahme carsten zeigt
un-bericht uns doch ein bisschen davon
wie es darum bestellt ist
wir erleben hier eine große und stetig
wachsende anteilnahme der berlinerinnen
und berliner hier ist eine gedenkstätte
improvisiert worden und wir sehen hier
dieses schild berlin trauert das hat
gerade eine frau hier unter tränen
angehängt und sie hat uns berichtet sie
hat sich so zurück erinnert gefühlt an
ihre eigene klassenfahrt in den 60er
jahren nach köln an den sprach
entschuldigung
an den spaß den sie damals hatten und
erleidet jetzt so richtig mit und mich
erinnert diese gedenkstätte natürlich an
die blumen und die kerzen die damals
nach dem anschlag 2016 genau da drüben
aufgestellt worden sind
als der lkw in den weihnachtsmarkt
gastes und hier sehen wir auch fast
wirklich fast absurd an wirken
anmutendes denn dort drüben ist alles
abgefordert dieser platz ist eine
festung diese barrieren dort die genau
verhindern sollen dass die lastwagen
oder fahrzeuge dort rauffahren und genau
auf der gegenüber liegenden straßenseite
dort wo ich jetzt stehe ist dieser
kleinwagen gestern in die menschenmenge
gerast und wir sehen jetzt hier auf der
straße noch die markierungen die die
polizei gemacht hat wo die verletzten
und auch die getötete lehrerin gelegen
hat nach diesem nach dieser tat muss man
wir jetzt sagen denn wir wissen jetzt
dass der täter offensichtlich
vorsätzlich gehandelt hat also die
anteilnahme und die betroffenheit diaz
riesengroß und dir wie du merkst reicht
bis zu mir ins innerste ja kasten zumal
wir wissen das aber wir sagen es an der
stelle auch noch mal was damals 2016
wirklich an dem tag auch da gegenüber
gottesdienst du hast das alles sehr
hautnah an dem tag mit angesehen und
miterlebt aber eben auch in den wochen
und monaten später in der begleitung
derjenigen die das auch erlebt haben
aber den punkt wenn du daran das
erscheint mir doch an dieser stelle
ausgesprochen wichtig zu sein das heißt
es gibt einerseits die schutzmaßnahmen
dort drüben ebenso schutz poller
aufzustellen und bei allen bestrebungen
bei allen bemühungen sich zu schützen
vor tätern muss man einsehen dann hat
man die eine seite geschützt und dann
passiert es gerade auf der anderen seite
wenn man das weiterdenkt wie groß wie
weit will man diese schutzmaßnahmen
ziehen und treiben um so etwas zu
verhindern muss man sozusagen an diesem
tag und an diesem ort wo du da stehst
irgendwie auch etwas hilflos
konzertieren einen hundertprozentigen
schutz kann und wird es nicht geben
das ist das was gestern abend auch die
regierende bürgermeisterin franziska
giffey gesagt hat wollen wir diese ganze
stadt zu holen möchten wir überall halt
solche barrieren hinstellen und ganz
ehrlich wenn jemand eine andere art von
attacke dann verübt nicht mit einem auto
sondern mit anderen waffen ich möchte da
nicht spekulieren aber ich glaube dann
merkt man sehr schnell dass es
illusorisch ist ein schutz einen
wirklichen schutz über eine ganze
millionenstadt oder über ein land wie
deutschland zulegen
das ist eine bittere erkenntnis aber ich
glaube sie liegt auf der hand dass es
keinen hundertprozentigen schutz geben
wird carsten wir sprechen gleich weiter
nutzen aber jetzt erst mal die
gelegenheit auf das aktuelle zu schauen
die staatsanwaltschaft in berlin hat
sich vor einer knappen halben stunde zu
dem neuen erkenntnissen geäußert wir
hören rein und sprechen dann weiter
hinsichtlich das gestrigen vorfall in
der tauentzienstraße
die staatschefs berlin bereitet gerade
den antrag auf einen
unterbringungsbefehl vor das ist noch in
arbeit das soll straße parallel dh die
entscheidung wird dann im laufe des
heutigen tages noch ein
ermittlungsrichter treffen und dann eben
wahrscheinlich antragsgemäß eben die
unterbringung des beschuldigten in einer
anstalt der psychiatrie
vorübergehend anordnen bis zur
hauptverhandlung
sie kennen den tatvorwurf der
beschuldigte soll gestern die
tauentzienstraße entlang gefahren sein
und dabei bewusst mit seinem fahrzeug in
zwei menschengruppen hinein gesteuert
sein einmal an der ecke zur rankestraße
die erste erfassung von personen und
dann auf der fahrspur in der
tauentzienstraße
das ganze entsprechend weiter und dort
dann eben in eine schülergruppe
hineingefahren sein bei der
schülergruppe handelt es sich um 24
schülerinnen und schüler aus hessen die
begleitende lehrerin ist noch vor ort
verstorben der begleitende lehrer ist
lebensbedrohlich verletzt von den
schülern selbst gibt es sieben
schwerverletzte die also stationär
behandelt werden es gibt sieben
leichtverletzte die gestern ambulant
behandelt werden mussten und darüber
hinaus gibt es insgesamt 17 weitere
personen auch aus diesem ersten vorfall
auf der fahrt heraus die ebenfalls
leicht bis schwer verletzt sind über das
genaue verletzungsbild da kann ich ihnen
keine konkreten angaben im augenblick
machen und unabhängig sozusagen von
diesen körperlichen verletzungen die da
festgestellt worden sind gab es gestern
insgesamt rund 50 personen die vor ort
psychologisch betreut werden mussten in
dem zusammenhang einfach haben wir noch
mal vorsorglich auch der hinweis die
senatsverwaltung für justiz viel zeit
und antidiskriminierung hatte das heute
morgen auch schon veröffentlicht berlin
hat seit 2008 zehn eine zentrale
anlaufstelle für die opfer von
terroristen und großschadensereignissen
und deren angehörigen insofern können
sich alle personen die hilfe suchen egal
ob mittelbar oder unmittelbar betroffen
von den gestrigen vorfällen auch dahin
wänden kriegen hilfsangebote vermittelt
bekommen der unterstützung und so weiter
die weiteren informationen sind dann auf
berlin.de
zentrale anlaufstelle zu bekommen zu dem
beschuldigten selbst was gestern noch
ein bisschen unsicher war hat sich jetzt
im laufe der heutigen ermittlungen noch
weiter
verhärtet es gibt also tatsächlich
anhaltspunkte dafür
das ist eine psychische beeinträchtigung
bei den beschuldigten gab die auch
anlass war für die gestrige tat man hat
im rahmen der durchsuchung medikamente
gefunden inzwischen hat er auch über
seinen verteidiger
behandelnde ärzte von der
schweigepflicht entbunden insofern
spricht recht viel für eine paranoide
schizophrenie was ist jedenfalls nicht
gibt sind anhaltspunkte für irgendeine
art von terroristischem hintergrund bei
dem ganzen geschehen aber
eben auch ein unfall wird sich vor
diesem hintergrund ausschließen lassen
das ist also die ganz aktuellen
informationen von seiten der
staatsanwaltschaft und damit noch mal
zurück carsten behrendt wie schon
angekündigt zu dir reden wir erst über
die opfern dann über den täter ich denke
das ist die richtige reihenfolge
wir haben es gehört es gab zwei
menschengruppe und vor allem eben diese
besagte schulklasse was kann man zur
stunde da an neuen erkenntnissen sagen
was hat sich da in den letzten stunden
ereignet
es ist so ich habe eben das war relativ
laut hier auf meinem kopfhörer nicht
alles gehört was ihr gesendet habt aber
in dem gesamten statement gab es für
mich einen ganz zentralen und eine ganz
wichtige information nämlich dass alle
schüler die schwerst verletzt war die
lebensgefährlich verletzt waren
mittlerweile außer lebensgefahr sind nur
noch ihr lehrer und das ist natürlich
schlimm genug ist noch in dem
lebensgefährlich verletzten zustand es
waren insgesamt sechs lebensgefährlich
verletzte wir probieren gerade noch
herauszufinden ob damit auch das
ausschließlich schüler und der lehrer
waren oder ob damit nur noch eine person
nämlich dieser zweite lehrer der die
gruppe begleitet hat in lebensgefahr
schwebt und die anderen immer noch
schwer verletzt im krankenhaus sind aber
ich finde das ist eine ganz wichtige und
ein stück weit auch beruhigende
nachricht dazu vielleicht noch wie
gesagt das waren 24 schüler insgesamt
sieben davon schwer verletzt die
lehrerin die diese schulklasse begleitet
hat ist vor ort verstorben und du hast
es gesagt der zweite lehrer zählt auch
noch zu den schwerverletzten
es gab eltern und gibt eltern die nach
berlin gekommen sind um ihre kinder in
obhut zu nehmen
was ist da denn aktuelle stand
nach unseren informationen ist sind die
schüler die zumindest körperlich und
verletzt worden wir haben natürlich alle
sehr gelitten und stehen unter dem
eindruck dieser tat sind zurückgekehrt
gestern abend in ihr hotel
es sind ist ein bus mit eltern und
schulpsychologen aus hessen gekommen die
eltern haben sich um ihre kinder
gekümmert und teilweise oder komplett
das haben wir noch nicht ganz sicher
sind sie auf dem heimweg jetzt nach
hessen zurück nach nordhessen in die
heimat und eben in der obhut ihrer
eltern und auch ein psychologischer
betreuung es gibt wie gesagt zwei
gruppen und insgesamt eine noch höhere
zahl an verletzten wir haben es gesagt
zwei menschengruppen wie gesagt die
bewerfen waren diese zentrale
anlaufstelle die da errichtet wurde sei
2018 also nach diesem amoklauf nach
dieser amokfahrt auf dem weihnachtsmarkt
hinter dir was bringt die was ist
sozusagen die erkenntnis aus dem was
schon einmal passiert ist was wir dort
geleistet
es war 2016 der anschlag und diese
anlaufstelle wurde ich muss mich
umdrehen dort drüben in der
gedächtniskirche eingerichtet das ist
eine erkenntnis die man gewonnen hat aus
dem anschlag weil viele betroffene
damals umhergeirrt sind die wussten
nicht wo sie sich hinwenden können und
eine erkenntnis zu sagen wir richten in
so einer situation sofort eine
betreuung mit seelsorgern ein wo die
menschen gesammelt werden wo sie auch
abgeschirmt werden und wo sie eben
intensiv betreut werden und sitzt dann
offen wirklich für alle menschen die an
dem was wir jetzt sagen tatort waren das
ist auch wichtig weil damit auch gleich
kontaktdaten aufgenommen werden können
für die polizei weil die menschen sind
natürlich auch nachdem sie betreut
worden sind wichtige zeugen die das
ganze miterlebt haben und das soll nach
dem was wir bislang gehört haben von
offizieller seite diesmal sehr gut
geklappt haben wie auch sonst leeren die
gezogen worden sind aus dem diesem
schweren anschlag 2016 umgesetzt worden
sind also das heißt diese dieses diese
alarmierung hier die hat auch bei den
einsatzkräften die erinnerung wach
gerufen und gesagt wir müssen jetzt
diesen ernstfall ausrufen das bedeutet
zum beispiel dass die polizei hier mit
sehr viel beamten eingeritten
eingefahren ist angerückt ist so um das
ist das richtige wort 150
beamte die den bereich sehr weit
abgesperrt haben die schwer bewaffnet
waren weil sie hat uns die polizei
erklärt man jetzt in so einem fall vom
schlimmsten aus geht und das schlimmste
ist natürlich es ist ein möglicher
terroranschlag es gibt vielleicht die
gefahr dass noch eine weitere attacke
folgt deswegen geht es um den schutz und
natürlich auch eine beweissicherung uns
wurde erklärt dass zum beispiel sehr
viel früher an das fahrzeug heran
gegangen worden ist und die
durchsuchungen stattgefunden hat das des
wagens da gab es den vorwurf dass der
lkw zu lange nicht richtig untersucht
worden ist und das offensichtlich so
wurde hat sich zumindest die polizei
gesagt dass wurde diesmal schneller
gemacht und auch da kann man auch mal
sagen den zusammenhang gestern gab es ja
die meldungen es geht ein
bekennerschreiben das hat sich jetzt hat
nach aussagen der behörden als falsch
herausgestellt dass es gab keinen kein
bekennerschreiben in diesem auto ja ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig das muss man
auch so deutlich noch mal sagen man geht
nicht vom terror aus kein
bekennerschreiben sprechen wir über den
beschuldigten gestern hieß es zunächst
als wir sprachen ungefähr
24 stunden etwas mehr dass der mann 60
seien inzwischen weiß man er ist 29
und offenkundig psychisch beeinträchtigt
er nimmt medikamente
und soll entsprechend vorläufig
zumindest erstmal in die psychiatrie
eingewiesen werden was weiß man noch
darüber hinaus
ja das war war sehr interessant was der
staatsanwaltschaft gerade gesagt hat
weil die aus der mittler kreisen gehört
haben diese psychische vorbelastung die
sollte man mit vorsicht genießen
zumindest nicht zu sehr in den
mittelpunkt rücken und der sprecher der
staatsanwaltschaft hat das aber als
zentralen punkt herausgestellt er hat
gesagt es gibt behandelnde ärzte bei
diesem mann es fiel das wort der
paranoiden schizophrenie
was die staatsanwaltschaft dazu bringt
dass er nicht in untersuchungshaft
kommen soll sondern das ist ein
unterbringungsbefehl in die psychiatrie
geben soll bis zum beginn der
verhandlung also das finde ich ist ein
ganz wichtiger punkt den wir jetzt auch
der für das weitere verfahren auch
wichtig sein wird weil
auch das hat der staatsanwalt anklingen
lassen wenn hier eine schwerwiegende
psychische erkrankung vorliegen sollte
dann könnte der mann schuldunfähig sein
und der vorwurf des wie er sagte
einfachen vollzogenen mordes und 31
fachen also die anzahl der verletzten 31
fachen versuchten mordes könnte dann
letztlich dazu führen dass wenn es ein
schuldspruch gibt das denn eine
unterbringung dauerhafte unterbringung
in der psychiatrie aber nicht zum
beispiel zu lebenslanger haft führen
könnte für nicht nur noch als
ergänzungen dazu er ist auch vorher
schon mal aufgefallen dass habe
ermittlungen gegeben wegen
körperverletzung hausfriedensbruch und
beleidigung über politisch und
extremistische taten hingegen ist nichts
bekannt carsten wir sprechen gleich
weiter schauen vielleicht gerade mal
zunächst noch mal welche reaktion ist
heute sonst noch gab von seiten der
insel autorin und der regierenden
bürgermeisterin der berichtet
schock und anteilnahme sind am tag nach
der amokfahrt groß die bundes
innenministerin spricht den angehörigen
der getöteten lehrerinnen und in 32
verletzten ihr mitgefühl aus und dankte
auch den einsatzkräften
ich bin vor allen dingen gekommen um den
einsatzkräften der feuerwehr der polizei
zu danken
hier wirklich großartigen einsatz die in
kürzester zeit eine sehr
unübersichtliche
sehr schnell im griff hatten insgesamt
waren 150 sanitäter innen und
feuerwehrleute im einsatz dazu noch mal
so viele polizistinnen zuvor ein auto
erst in einer gruppe von passantinnen
und dann in dieses schaufenster gerast
umstehende gegen den 29 jährigen fest
und übergaben ihn der polizei gegen den
in berlin lebenden deutsch armenischen
staatsbürger gebe es nach ersten
ermittlungen keine staatsschutz
relevanten erkenntnisse so die berliner
innensenator in im abgeordnetenhaus nach
einer medizinischen untersuchung aber
erkenntnisse über psychologische
probleme des mannes mit unserer
mordkommission natürlich dran wir gehen
davon aus dass es keine politische
motivation gab die trauer ist groß in
der schule der betroffenen im hessischen
bad essen genauso wie in berlin an der
gedächtniskirche legen menschen blumen
nieder und fragen nach dem warum
carsten abschließend noch mal schnell
das warum wird wahrscheinlich nie
beantwortet werden aber wie erlebst du
die stadt man sieht natürlich ist wieder
normaler straßenverkehr hinter dir die
stadt dort an diesem ach so wichtigen
punkt wirklich kaum zentraler geht es ja
gar nicht in berlin
einerseits sozusagen wie der alltag der
nächste weihnachtsmarkt wird irgendwann
kommen und doch ist es wieder eine wunde
das heißt das für berlin
erst mal haben wir den hochsommer und
der weihnachtsmarkt hat jetzt mit dem
mit dieser tat jetzt nicht wirklich was
zu tun aber sicher es ist eine wunde und
es wird wenn es in richtung dieser
psychologischen diagnose hinläuft dass
das der mann eben wirklich eine schwere
erkrankung hat und die tat ursächlich
sein soll das wird gelinde gesagt für
kopfschütteln sorgen weil viele menschen
nicht verstehen dass jemand dann nicht
für so eine tat ins gefängnis geht wir
hatten einen ähnlichen fall bin ich ganz
kurz erwähnen möchte auf der autobahn
2020 stadtautobahn ist ein mann
ein motorradfahrer gezielt rhein gerast
hat die umgenietet da wurde auch eine
genau dieses erkrankungs muster
diagnostizierte er war am ende
schuldunfähig weil er gesagt hat dass
neben ihm ein schwarzer todesengel
gesessen hat der mensch steuer gegriffen
hat auch da gab es viele viel
kopfschütteln danach und ich denke das
wird viele menschen wütend machen dass
es dass es ebenso ist aber insofern wird
wird dieses diese frage nach dem warum
wird keine befriedigende antwort geben
und insofern bleibt an der stelle glaube
ich nur zu trauern und und anteilnahme
zu zeigen und auch zu hoffen dass die
schwerverletzten jetzt den waffen des
wortes durchkommen und keine zu schweren
bleibenden schäden nach dieser
schrecklichen tat behalten werden danke
für diese schilderung live aus berlin
vom tatort von einem
amoklauf so muss man mittlerweile sagen
von dem wir wissen das ist eine war es
war kein unfall es war auch kein terror
aber es war die tat eines mannes der
offenkundig jetzt erstmal in die
psychiatrie muss und gehört und berlin
muss leben damit erstmal umzugehen danke
carsten behrendt
das sind keine schönen erkenntnisse und
vor allem auch keine wie wir gerade
schon gehört haben auf die es eine wie
auch immer geartete zufriedenstellende
antwort gibt aber natürlich muss man
sich fragen kann man sich schützen
welche form von schutz kann es geben
oder womit müssen wir lernen zu leben in
diesem sinne erstmal das ist das
aktuelle was wir zu diesem tag sagen
können zu dieser tat auch danke für euer
interesse und bis bald